welcome to the man of recaps this is
house of the dragon episode two so at
the end of episode one the king viserys
targaryen decided to name his daughter
ranira heir to the iron throne but
they're not really treating her like the
future queen right now she attends small
council meetings but pouring the wine
not with a seat at the table and the
main issue this episode is that everyone
wants king viserys to remarry so he can
have more kids and get a real male heir
and so it's time for the bachelor king's
landing now king viserys really loved
his wife so he's still depressed about
it and the person he's getting comfort
from right now is young alice in ty
tower daughter of his most trusted
advisor hand of the king otto hightower
it's not a romantic relationship at the
moment she just keeps him company while
he plays with his model city but
remember it is her father who's
encouraging her to hang out with the
king so he's power climbing and remember
allison is ranira's best friend but she
doesn't tell her yet that she's flirting
with her dad but the top marriage
proposal the king's considering is from
cordless valerian remember he's married
to the king's cousin rhaenys targaryen
the one who's passed over back in the
big council the queen who never was they
have a daughter who's almost of age and
it would be a great match because the
valerians are a very powerful house and
the valerians and targaryens both
descended from old valyria the great old
empire across the sea so it would like
you know strengthen the bloodline so the
king agrees to go on a date with her
daughter elena but when i said she's
almost of age like in another couple
years she's 12 right now you know in
medieval politics sometimes you got to
lock that patrol down early but viserys
is kind of creeped out by it so while
her father's on a date with his second
cousin raniere is having a convo with
her second cousin rhaenys and you'd
think these two might be friends as two
strong targaryen women but really
they're kind of sass in each other
ranier is like yo it doesn't matter if
my father remarries he named me air but
rhaenys is like yo you see what's
happening here they want to replace you
men would sooner put the round to the
torch and see a woman ascend the iron
throne but now there's a new problem
from the king's brother damon targaryen
who the king renounced as his air last
episode but damon decided to kind of
ignore that he took a little army and
occupied dragonstone the castle off the
coast that is where the heir always
lives he hasn't been bothering anyone so
they didn't want to start a fight
they're just ignoring him but now he's
come back and stolen a dragon egg he
left a letter saying he's marrying his
mistress and she's pregnant so he needs
a dragon egg in the targaryen tradition
to put in the cradle with the baby but
they only do that with the kids of the
king not of the king's brother so they
gotta get that back so we're selling off
to dragonstone and if you remember this
is where stannis lived for most of game
of thrones and where daenerys landed
later yeah with the big stone bridge
damon's here cool as a cucumber being
kind of a cocky guy remember he and the
hand auto hightower really don't like
each other so now it's like yo bro you
gotta give that egg back and stop
calling yourself the air or it's gonna
come to blows damon's like yo you want
the egg come and take it and it looks
like it might come to blows which would
be very bad for otto because don't
forget damon has a dragon and it's like
a crazy designed like long necks greecey
dolphin dragon but wait what's that in
the mist it's another dragon yavanira
decided to fly on over with hers to
remind everyone i'm a dragon rider she
goes up to talk to her uncle targaryen
to targaryen and these two aren't
enemies we saw in episode one they kinda
like each other you know they're family
but she's like yo uncle you're taking it
too far here it's going from a family
squabble to full-blown treason you
either give me that egg back right now
or you may as well kill me and declare
civil war it's a tense standoff but in
the end damon doesn't want that so he
caves tosses her back the egg and civil
war is avoided for now now by the way
demon's mistress masaria is not pregnant
and he didn't tell her that they were
getting married and having a baby and
she is not interested she's happy enough
to be his mistress but entering the game
of thrones is a good way to get her head
on a spike with the damon issue result
for now it's back to king viserys's
search for a new wife he has a heart to
heart with his daughter in era like hey
i loved your mother and i love you but i
have to remarry it's what's best for the
realm and rainier is like pops you're
the king i get it you do what you got to
do so the next morning he's announcing
his engagement to the small council and
everyone agrees laina valerian is the
right choice but the king goes for the
surprise move and announces he's
marrying alison hightower yes while all
his advisors spent the episode saying
lana valerian's the clear choice his
hand otto hightower was like you gotta
follow your heart and behind the scenes
he's talking to his daughter like hey
spend more time with the king so she
goes in there and fixed his dragon
miniature for him which won him over so
otto hightower playing the game of
thrones real hard naturally this pisses
off for nera whose dad's now engaged to
her best friend and neither of them gave
her the heads up but this pisses off
coreless valerian even more rejecting a
proposal kind of a slap in the face and
cordless valerian's already mad at the
king over another issue the crab beater
yes this pirate's been terrorizing
shipping lanes in the stepstones and
shipping his corpus valerian's whole
thing he's been asking permission to
send his navy down there to stop him but
the king was like hey that might anger
the free cities i can't allow it so
corliss goes home and has a meeting with
damon targaryen it's like hey man why
don't you and i team up for a little
unofficial mission to take out this crab
beater this would make the king mad and
undermine his authority but it's not
full-blown treason yet in fact when
damon's like yeah my brother's a weak
king and cortis valerian's like yeah man
he sucks damon's like whoa whoa i'm
allowed to talk smack about my brother
you can't talk smack about your king but
these two are teaming up to take down
the crab feeder and that's where episode
2 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]